ich habe jetzt in den letzten tagen mit
einigen mietern gesprochen die sehr
unzufrieden waren mit modernisierung
nebenkostenabrechnung ja wenn sie uns
den namen geben dann setzten uns gerne
mit den mietern zusammen
das lustige ist diese von denen haben
angst ihre namen zu nennen ja das ist
traurig das ist traurig und dann
gastieren die traurigkeit nicht ab
[Musik]
erinnerst du dich eigentlich noch an
deinen ersten einsatz für die heute-show
klar sowas vergisst man nicht viele
menschen aufgeheizte stimmung und lautes
gegröle also ein public viewing area
also in public screens genau deswegen
sind wir natürlich auch nicht als lügen
presse hin gegangen sondern als russia
today kids
mit
[Musik]
haben sie kurz zeit wir versuchen so ein
kleines bild zur deutschen einheit in
dresden einzufangen ist ja viel unseren
anderen worten hier dafür abgestellt
wurden
das ist nicht so wie sonst die heute als
sehr hübsches nicht nein hat merkel
jetzt aber hier noch mal nachgelegt als
fernsehen kommt wahrscheinlich nein ein
persönlicher traum in erfüllung ich
treffe die den bundespolizei der ton ist
ausgelassene stimmung wie sieht's mit
das war ja hallo ich bin von russia
today kids warum sind sie heute hier
ich möchte verhindern dass man gar nicht
mehr kennen ist untergang europas und
drang untergang deutschlands untergang
europas
das ist untergegangen was hier abläuft
also ich habe wenig verstanden aber was
passt dann darf war untergang untergang
euro was will ich verhindern
ich finde es ist unglaublich was man
hier macht dass man so viele reihen
lässt es geht einfach nicht dass
naturgesetzlich das ist gegen die natur
auch in anderen dingen also ist das so
ein physikalisches gesetz wie wenn was
runterfällt
etwas selbst oder etwas sich etwas
kaputt gemacht wird weil andere tag
kommen ein naturgesetz
die tourismuszahlen gegengeraden zurück
wenn jetzt so ein tourist hierher kommen
was würdest du ihm empfehlen was man
unbedingt sehen die altstadt allgemein
kann man sehr viel sagen aber man muss
jetzt sagen nicht zum montag also
montags dresden meiden genau eben ist
dadurch dass sich der takt entscheidet
ist eben das montag tag genau zum montag
und natürlich so wie merkel wieder
scheiße gebaut hätte man wissen können
dass am montag in dresden fertig ist die
live übertragung bis jetzt noch nicht
soll das eine leichte fragen können sie
sich gerne interviews bei live ansonsten
traurig keiner medien ja es ist das ist
eine live-übertragung auf
haben sie sich ja mein haus ist eine
ameise nicht und dann noch eine und noch
eine jahr gut
also ich bin den menschen freundin
tierfreund dann schaffe ich dir aus was
sie nicht tut dann noch einmal kommt
einfach zu arbeiten die laufen dann
durch über dicke hier und und verstehen
sie die masse macht ich mir doch nichts
gegen ausländer so angela merkel hat
mich die gesamte bundespolizei
angefordert heute ist es eher ruhig es
ist ja auch eigentlich nichts zu
befürchten
es ist ja nicht feindliches gebiet oder
sowas sondern die menschen freuen sich
auf merkel
und deswegen braucht man eigentlich auch
keine polizei läuft unbedingt europa
immer noch immer noch ja ich weiß nicht
wann steigt fürs jahren wird europa
muslim nicht sein und und dann und dein
zimmer ein muslimisches land ja und was
ist jetzt das negative nenne das das
muss liebe nicht wird viele leute wissen
gar nicht dass frau merkel vor der wende
das recht hatte in die usa zu reisen
der verdacht dass diese frauen ist ja ja
gerne diesmal wohl noch nicht geäußert
die kanzlerin dürfte in den westen
fahren
das ist eine tatsache oder verdacht
stehen den büchern ich kann das
natürlich bestätigen aber es steht in
den büchern im internet noch eine andere
frage sie feiern ihr ja heute den tag
der deutschen einheit aber am dritten
oktober war der anschluss von österreich
doch gar nicht deutsche einheit von ost
und west
das ist ja an der feier wo merkel
teilnehmen nein das hier ist auch
deutschland genauso
genauso ist es 89 ja ich dachte der
anschluss von österreich wird bekommen
sie noch so was ja dass so eine pizza
demo hier oder nicht auch drückt ja
damit ist doch alles gesagt nein ich
habe auch gehört dass die usa hinter der
deutschen einheit steckt
es gibt bücher medizin einsetzen da sie
ja gemacht hat will sich zwei das
sozusagen ihr wisst ja hier wird man
direkt angegangen
meine mütze wurde geklaut ist natürlich
meine frisur durcheinander von alten
männern an getanzt und angegangen zu
werden
aber was sollen wir machen ja bitte ich
wollte nur darauf hinweisen
dass man frau merkel ihre politik unter
dem gesichtspunkt betrachten sollte ob
sie vielleicht doch nicht
die kassen ist diese vorgibt sondern
eine agentin
ja ich hab gehört man hat dir deine
musik laut wir kommen jetzt warum
organisieren die wieder zurückwarfen
staat ich hab da was organisiert das
habe ich hab ein
du hast wir ordentlich auf die mütze
bekommen
man sieht immer wieder für unsere besser
scharfe satire sind wir zurecht
preisgekrönt wie war denn eigentlich
dein erster heute schon dreht auf der
süßwarenmesse okay dann habe ich jetzt
auch ein du hast du nicht auf die fresse
bekommen sondern in die fresse ja und
zwar zucker pur
was ist denn der unterschied zwischen
zucker und crack fragen sich manche
leute ganz einfach track schreibt man
mit c und 17
das ist wunderbar
hallo das ist die frage wie viel vor so
einer messe muss man den aufhören
süßigkeiten zu essen am besten
ballfänger drei wochen davor an
sonst sieht man dann so aus wie dieses
fette schweine entschuldigung sie müssen
schaffst das
schwarzer zucker ist das gesünder oder
weniger gesucht auf jeden fall gesünder
können sie das noch mal sagen und dann
so die kamera zwingen kann auf jeden
fall gesünder
also so ganz können sie machen sie mit
beiden augen sagen schwarz und weiß auf
jeden fall gesehen und dann nannte mit
beiden augen zwingen kann ist auf jeden
fall cool das auf jeden fall gesünder
[Musik]
manchmal trügt der schein und selbst
leute die zu schwer wirken sind
eigentlich gar nicht übergewichtig es
sind eigentlich sehr sehr schlanke
personen gefangen den körper von sehr
dickem das nennt man auch transfette
colitis chocolate wenn sie das auch zum
beispiel einem kind aus syrien sagen ja
klar
und wie soll das dann reagieren zu
können
man braucht auch zucker ein etwas
unkonventioneller schokobrunnen
inspiriert an den ehemaligen toiletten
des antiken roms das ist ungewiss
ja das ist also der erste coupé der
jetzt in den markt kommt mit koran und
das ist natürlicher koffein das heißt
wenn sie zwei von diesem wunderschönen
cookie essen dann haben sie so viel wie
werden sie eine dose energy drink
trinken aber das entnehme ich dann ganz
normal oral ein und nicht irgendwie so
zerbröseln und mit der nase nähen das
leben sie so einen wie sie normalerweise
ihre nahrung aufnehmen ich weiß nicht
wie sie das sonst machen aber wenn sie
so machen sie sonst machen haben sie
genau den richtigen weg sie sind
unglaublich hässlich was ist denn sie
sind wieder nur dieses kostüm aus können
sie auch so was praktisches wie zum
beispiel eine insulinspritze modellieren
insulinspritze etwas spezielles wir
machen das
aber zum glück ist diabetes nicht das
einzige was man hier mitnehmen kann und
damit zurück ins studio
[Musik]
hazel ich bin echt enttäuscht
hier steht das ganze weite feld der
peter altmaier wird so offen und du hast
keinen einzigen ja während du dich mit
belangloser politik beschäftigt setze
ich mich mit den wahren bösewichten
unserer zeit auseinander
karius und baktus und ich beschäftige
mich mit dem thema honig muss echt noch
viel lernen
eine ganz normale wohnsiedlung oder vivo
novia sagt geldquelle
wie funktioniert dieses prinzip unter
anderem mit umbauten dass sie jetzt hier
den bau machen und uns auf dieses haus
noch eine etage drauf setzen wollen die
sagen es dauert zwölf monate bis das
fertig ist und welche haben angepasst in
der familie erhöhung gibt also ich bei
meiner wohnung mindestens 250 euro mehr
bezahlen man muss ja auch mal an die
aktionäre denke ja wahrscheinlich
aktualisieren überhaupt nicht aber was
sagt nobia dazu ich habe jetzt in den
letzten tagen mit einigen mietern
gesprochen die sehr unzufrieden waren
mit modernisierung nebenkostenabrechnung
ja wenn sie uns den namen geben dann
setzten uns gerne mit den mietern
zusammen
das lustige ist viele von denen haben
angst ihre namen zu nennen ja das ist
traurig das ist traurig und dann haben
wir gefunden haben die traurigkeit nicht
ab aber was haben sie für nebenkosten es
wird ein winterdienst abgerechnet wenn
entweder kein schnee fällt oder es fällt
schnee
aber es kommt auch kein winterdienst
wann ist denn der winterdienst in der
regel unterwegs er ist nicht morgens um
6 unterwegs sondern erst morgens um vier
unterwegs natürlich ist es dann häufig
für die mieter in dem haus nie sichtbar
und dann hat es danach geschneit und
deswegen hat der mieter das dann nicht
mitbekommen und dann am nächsten tag kam
das sehr gute streu unternehmen hat
gestreut dann dass es dann passiert es
hat glauben sie es oder nicht es hat
geschneit
und dann ist der ball via mieter wieder
aufgewacht man das gibt's doch nicht
hier ist ja schon wieder nicht gestreut
worden
wir können mit einzelfall ankommt meint
wir haben interesse daran dass unsere
nebenkosten überhitzen
daran haben wir kein interesse haben wir
nicht wir sind sehr verlässlich was die
dividenden angeht
in berlin gibt es die idee große
wohnungskonzern einfach zu enteignen
wir testen die stimmung auf dem
deutschen immobilien kongress enteignung
kann jetzt nicht kein kommentar thema
enteignung danke thema enteignung die
leute laufen wirklich kommen wir weg die
ganze zeit hallo schön guten tag thema
enteignung
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass damit die probleme
dieser stadt lösten aber es sind ja doch
überraschend viele berliner dafür
wenn sie diese fragen würden ob täglich
freibier geben würde würde es
wahrscheinlich auch dafür stimmen in den
mieter klagen aber ja auch darüber dass
die immobilienkonzerne die preise
unnötig hoch treiben mit falschen
nebenkostenabrechnungen zum beispiel
naja also offen gesagt so gut wie keiner
kann sich in diesem regulatorischen raum
den wir haben anders verhalten als der
gesetzliche rahmen ist vor gibt ja wir
versuchen heute schon mal herauszufinden
wie die immobilienbranche reagiert wenn
sie denn enteignet wird jetzt zum
beispiel trinken sie den kaffee noch
also ich wüsste jetzt offen gesagt nicht
warum nicht weil enteignung im sinne von
wetten dass mein café ja ja also den
würde ich jetzt enteignen
ja dann würde ich sagen also der preis
für diesen kaffee ist aus meiner sicht
gerade mal 15 euro und jetzt lasst uns
mal unterhalten so ist nämlich die
rechtslage
hallo frau kramp karrenbauer
ich freue mich auch sie sind ja gegen
enteignung aber andererseits hat die cdu
doch jahrelang die spd skrupellos
enteignet danke hat kommt in die
lüneburger heide
da kann man noch für fünf euro oder 6
teuren quadratmetern der wohnung bekommt
man halt in der lüneburger heide dann
wird man in der lüneburger heide
aber wenn man natürlich so berlin in
hamburg man sich auch gleich erschießen
ne danke schön und sie in der lüneburger
heide natürlich so heftig dass er
wirklich gedacht enteignung ist
keinesfalls umsetzbar weil das
widersinnig ist und entgegen jedem song
jeglicher gesellschaftlicher
grundordnung widerspricht und damit
natürlich auch insofern von uns bzw
vordergrund entsprechend vorangebracht
wird
das war klar und deutlich ja das thema
enteignung wird hier beim immobilien
kommen wir dass 2019 sehr positiv
aufgenommen ich glaube dass es klar
geworden und damit zurück ins studio
frage an das war richtig gut aus so dass
den konfirmanden anzug abiball aber du
kannst ja auch richtig seriös seien
damals mal den jamaika verhandlungen da
was wir mittendrin
ja ich hab damals zwischen cdu und
grünen alles klar gemacht und dann hat
der lindner ist versorgt malen christian
koalitionsverhandlungen musst du den
profis überlassen oder wenigstens hazel
ich möchte diesen prozess gerne ein
bisschen beschleunigen habe mir daher
ein paar junge politiker der jeweiligen
parteien eingeladen
die cool freshen typen die die richtig
wissen was so abgeht
und ja ich möchte noch anmerken die fdp
ist ja heute nicht da aber ich werde
dann einfach ein paar mal soli
abschaffen und obergrenze innenraum
schmeißen damit sich so anfühlt als
wären fdp und csu auch da vielleicht ein
kleines spiel zum kennenlernen das
wollknäuel spiel ich würde jetzt ihnen
herr lindner dieses wollknäuel geben und
können sie den faden festhalten sie
sagen ihren namen setzen dann das
wollknäuel weiter zu einem beliebigen
weiteren politikern raum und wenn dann
jeder das wort nur einmal gehabt dass
lindner ja ich bin eigentlich immer wenn
sie das wollen müssen sie etwas sagen
ich bin seit 2011 im bundestag
ich bin neu dabei seit 2017 im gespannt
ob man zwar weiterhin bekommen eine
schöne insel ist es ob es nur für eine
koalition mit werden das sehen
ich freue mich auf jamaika
vielleicht kommen wir jetzt zu
inhaltlichen themen ist das klima cool
naja das klima ist im moment zu heiß um
ehrlich zu sein und so mal lobt zu
beginn zwar richtig dass die kanzlerin
in paris ein klima abkommen
unterschrieben hat da hat sie sich ja
dazu verpflichtet dass wir in
deutschland co2 emissionen reduzieren
aber dass ich habe ja die saubersten
dieselmotoren vw also das will man ja na
ja das will man noch mal deutlich sagen
werden deutschland produzieren die
saubersten am besten dieselmotoren in
die weltweit mit produziert werden das
ist so ein bisschen wie wenn man die
waffen herstellt die am wenigsten weh
tun oder also die saubersten
dieselmotoren es ist ja immer noch nicht
sauber
das ist nicht sauber da gebe ich ihnen
recht gut
weiters gemacht flüchtlingskrise
eigentlich ein thema das finde ich
selber nicht geeignet um scherze darüber
zu machen was mir persönlich zu ernst
wieso stellt die csu dennoch so alberne
forderungen die ganze zeit herr müller
gut das sind keine albernen forderung
die csu stellt das ist realpolitik und
das ziel 200.000 menschen ab wann ist
man ein mensch ist ist man mit zwölf
schon ein fertiger mensch oder braucht
man zwei zwölfjährige was ist wenn man
drei kinder übereinander stapelt und die
in einen großen trend sportplatz dann
eine person also für uns als cdu und csu
da kann ich sicherlich auch für unsere
schwesterpartei sprechen als christliche
menschenbild ist jeder gleichwertig was
ist schlimmer für deutschland schwarzer
afghane oder reguläre aufgaben
hinzu von schwarzen aufgaben muss man
natürlich regulieren nicht für
minderjährige nur ein staatlich
reglementierten verkaufstellen sich da
mal übereinander gelegt in einem mord
programm
und dann kommt das hier aus ist der
sogenannte visuelle huber deshalb
manchmal gut also an kompromiss die
grünen lassen sich auch von horst
seehofer herumkommandieren und dafür
übernimmt die cdu seine pflege sondern
weil wir würden auch aus seo von meinem
wahlkreis wegen aber jetzt übrigens auch
zu gast sind der brauchte er keine ärzte
um horst seehofer zu pflegen sondern wir
brauchen pflege pflege gerne
kommandieren nicht okay aber pflege
übernimmt ja die cdu also sie können ja
nicht einfach sagen also jetzt wie ich
möchte mich jetzt nicht mit den grünen
streiten der horst seehofer schlägt ja
aber ohne quatsch wir würden horst
seehofer gerne es lägen auch in meiner
heimat ich würde sagen es ist zeit den
koalitionsvertrag ist nun unterschreiben
ich habe mir etwas vorbereitet herr
lindner möchten sie anfangen mit was
muss ich wundervoll mit fast 400 mit
meinen
aber ich kann natürlich für die cdu
nicht unterschreiben das kann ich mir
jetzt nicht anmaßen
wir haben da eine parteivorsitzende die
entsprechenden gremien aber ich kann es
natürlich auch bei uns groß ist es
wichtig da gibt's gremien unterhalten
wir uns also sie waren das nicht
unterscheiden
ich unterschreibe ich sehr gerne den
koalitionsvertrag sofern die inhalte
stimmen und dann gibt's halt neuwahlen
[Applaus]
kann man noch einen joint trotz drehen
ist selbst braucht jetzt eher er gibt es
eigentlich eine obergrenze für seehofer
pflege.de also da kann es nicht genug
geben
aber wenn du seehofer pflegt dann stelle
ich mich persönlich auf den balkon und
applaudieren die man kann ja mit pflege
richtig cash machen
ach ja jetzt nicht als pfleger als
investor
so schnell kann's gehen da redet man
einmal die pflegerin wird überfahren
ja es ist habe ich mit reinkommen weiße
stadtwerken gemeldet sind hier sie ihr
pressesprecher hat uns verboten
jetzt habe ich ja ewig in die
veranstaltung muss auch das presse
statement warten
von daher mache ich mir derzeit einfach
mal selbst ein bild und geht ins alter
sie sind herr köster ja schön dass wir
nicht da sind immer ihre sachen und der
ablauf seit heute und das morgen los
aber ganz schön viel eher das muss so
und jetzt gesetzt und spielt sehr gut
[Musik]
sie haben eine schöne frisur ich tue
mein bestes um so mehr
[Musik]
würden sie einem jungen menschen raten
pfleger zu werden ist ein harter arbeit
alltag den sie so auf naja sind 31
schon wieder geworden
[Musik]
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen schon
anstrengend ich glaube ich kann besser
unterhaltung wenn sie mein hallo berlin
seid ihr gut drauf ja ich fange direkt
mit dem klassiker an
kennen sie bestimmt alle kommt ein pferd
ende war sagt der barkeeper warum das
lange gesichter nach dem ablegen
da habe ich direkt noch einen für euch
wie nennt man einen reichen pfleger erbe
der ist hintergründig sie haben sie fast
okay einen habe ich noch woran erkennt
man rainer brüderle im fernsehen an den
untertitel das was von mir vielen dank
berlin
danke ja ich weiß halt wie man laden zum
kochen bringt und jetzt geht's noch mal
zum brüderle die beschäftigten bescheid
wenn jedes jahr mehr beschäftigt den
privaten unternehmen gehen
das ist deren entscheidung aus gute
überlegung aus was würden sie sagen ist
cleverer wenn die pflegeversicherung
einzahlen oder einfach direkt in heim-
investieren und dann davon leben von der
rendite
richten sie mal helge herzliche grüße
aus nachdem er eine sehr lange
sommerpause genommen hat würde ich ihr
glück auf für seine weiter
jetzt sind wir wieder da und sie sind ja
auf den gebieten echter experte eine
koryphäe sie kennen sich wirklich sehr
gut aus
deswegen meine frage welchen wein soll
ich kaufen will dabei machen sie gute
sendungen produzieren sind hat die
vermisste auf dem bildschirm und
strengen sich an wie dazu ich habe das
gefühl sie hören wenn ich richtig zu das
passt ja auch zum thema pflege
da darf ich rainer brüderle doch noch
fragen stellen und er redet beim thema
pflege nur über welke aber all i lass
dir nichts sagen so alt bist du noch
nicht und wenn was ist ich bin für dich
da
und damit zurück ins pflege studie ist
sogar eine ehre wenn du solche witze
über goalie machst das ist ja das gute
er hat es nach zwei minuten wieder
vergessen die pflege wird zu gehen heim
aber auch nicht aus also so ein
praktikum in der pflege ist schon
ziemlich krass aber ich glaube ich kann
das noch toppen noch härter und
trauriger als der pflegealltag das kann
ja nur eins bedeuten ein praktikum bei
der spd
hier ist lars klingbeil von der spd ist
es jetzt 37 und wir waren eigentlich um
7 uhr verabredet
[Musik]
so kamen die neuenburger ich bin so was
wie die geräte tun werk der deutschen
comedy szene
ja das tun ist da vielleicht mal ganz
gut ich mache vielleicht den ein oder
anderen bösen witz heute aber ich denke
das ist dann ist klug und in einer
studie ja nichts wird so schön sagen wie
die eigentliche situation in der sie
sich gerade so ich muss jetzt wird's
parlament wir haben jetzt die
generaldebatte die kanzlerin spricht und
du fängst du schon mal an und
beantworten also die kriegen immer so
bürger anfragen per e-mail oder per post
an das hier ist etwas zum klimaschutz
paket wenn es um eine co2 steuer geht
sollte auch das pferd nicht vergessen
werden die millionen freizeitpferde
stehen auf den weiden und verrichten
ihre notdurft und bringen ungezählt das
nitrat in den boden hat es das hier
zurückgeschreckt sie sprechen vom
freizeitwert lustig denn so nenne ich
meine ehefrau auch manchmal
ich kann mich über meine frau reden sie
wieder weg wenn der anspruch selbst
abgeordnete zu werden dann muss man das
ganze so ein schreiben den sandy wieder
das ist doch gut
da kann ich meine unterschrift darunter
setzen
ich versuche so alle zwei wochen
irgendwie mal nur ein format zu machen
facebook live instagram live oder
instagram pivot allem mit fragen stellen
können jetzt versucht mal so auszusehen
als fans des mega cool wie bist du zur
politik gekommen wisse lustig antworten
oder was weiß mit soße oder ich gehe
einfach bei deinen sachen ein bisschen
problem du hast eine sehr niedrige
gedichtet
grüßte denen auch immer so nett oder nur
weil ich jetzt dabei den nötigen größe
deutlich machen wie ein fahrstuhl geht
die tür oft entsteht da die beide drin
uns oder will man dann gar nicht in den
fahrschulen
so etwas würde ich nie tun
du musst ja schon ganz schön viel
arbeiten oder ja das gehört dazu
ist doch kraft wie viel du erreichen
willst wenn du einer sinnvollen
tätigkeit nach sie traktieren dienstag
der spd-bundestagsfraktion 15 uhr geht's
los meisten ist bis 19 uhr
wie stelle ich mir das vor sowie ein
poetry-slam aber alle verlieren das ding
ja auch für alle spd fans zuschauen wenn
man hier einmal die fraktion sieht 92
[Musik]
im letzten video auf für die spd in
oldenburg die 250 jahre und der schicken
grußbotschaft wer bei uns mitglied ist
kann auch in zukunft für fortschritt und
zusammenhalt in unserem land sorgen da
musste ich dann richtig drauf setzen
dass die zeit haben oder versuche ernst
zu sagen und das kommt wissen hier mach
einfach nur so als wäre es nicht ein
witz und dann sagen die kurve zu kurve
spielt kann es auch was erfinden musste
eigentlich okay und action liebe
genossinnen und genossen herzliche grüße
nach
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt mit kevin kühnert du
wirst so was wie der philipp am tor der
spd januar können wir so stehen das ist
jetzt so wie die entwicklung des
menschen aber ich weiß wir finden das
noch heraus im moment ist die pizza
meinen abendessen ich weiß nicht bei dir
wahrscheinlich auch wir quatschen suche
nur politik ich habe vier jahreszeiten
angeht ich glaube ich hätte ja auch
genommen das sind die vier jahreszeiten
beide user dreimal herbst einmal winter
nein ich es immer früher wir stehen am
anfang der blüte sozusagen und das kennt
das auch noch der war ja auch mal bei
den jusos unterwegs knospe sagen auch
sehr lange zu dieser habe dann wird die
blüte umso schöner
im gegensatz zum elend in der spd hat
diese arbeitstag wenigstens ein ende
vielen dank und dadurch ins studio aber
die spd kann einem echt leitungen oder
ständig dieser bedürftige hilferuf nach
unterstützung ja schlimm aber weißt du
wie man uns also die heute show auch
unterstützen kann
mit einem abo auf unserem youtube kanal
und einem like unter diesem video und
das ist noch nicht alles nein ich muss
bekloppt sein obendrauf gibt es noch die
neue bester folge in der zdf mediathek
super hammer geilomat das würde mich
wahnsinnig machen immer so nachhilfe zu
flehen ja schlimm spd tut mir echt leid